the greatest common divisor of two
numbers is easy a computer and that's a
fact that will play a crucial role in
the number theory that we're going to
develop and the properties of some of
the modern codes that are based on
number theory the efficient way to
compute the GCD of two numbers is based
on a classical algorithm known as
nucleating an algorithm which is several
thousand years old and let's describe
how it works now so the Euclidean
algorithm is based on the following
lemma which we'll call the remainder
lemma and it says that if a and B are
two integers then the greatest common
divisor of a and B is the same as the
greatest common divisor of B and the
remainder of a divided by B providing of
course B is not zero because otherwise
you can't divide my movie okay oh how do
you make sense out of this how why is
this true well it's actually a very easy
proof remember that by the so-called
division algorithm or it's really a
theorem if you take if you divide a by B
and we're doing inter division and what
that means is you find a quotient of a
divided by being the quotient and a
remainder and the commotions has the
property that Q times B plus the
remainder is equal to a the remainder is
always going to be smaller than a it'll
be in the range from 0 up to but not
including a ok if you look at this
simple expression what it becomes
apparent is that if you've got a divisor
of two out of three of these terms then
it's going to divide the third term so
for example if you have a divisor of B
and R then the sum of those two things
is also going to have the same divisor
which means that a will have that
divisor if something divides both a and
B then it divides R and if it divides B
and R it divides a and that means that a
and B and B and R have exactly the same
divisors they not only have the same
green as
devisor all their divisors are the same
so obviously the greatest one is the
same and that proves this key remainder
llama
well the remainder lemon now gives us a
very lovely way and compute the GCD and
here's an example suppose I want to
compute the GCD of 899 and 493 a is 899
B is 493 well so I want this GCD 899
afford 93 well according to the
remainder lemma if I divide 899 by 493 I
get a quotient of 1 and a remainder of
406 and so that means that 899 and 493
have the same GCD as 493 and 406 well
that is as the original number B and the
new remainder 406 but now I can divide
493 by 406 I get a quotient of 0 and a
remainder of 87 so 406 and 87 have the
same GCD dividing 406 by 87 I get that
87 and 58 have the same GCD dividing 87
by 58 I get that 58 and 29 have the same
GCD and now I win because look when I
divide a 58 by 29 I get a remainder of 0
and the GCD of anything n0 is that
thinks of the GCD of 29 and 0 is 0 I
guess the only exception is the GCD of 0
and 0 which is not defined but if it's
if it's not 0 then the GCD of X and 0 is
X and there it is so I've just found
that the GCD of 899 and 493 is 29 and
this is a quite fast algorithm because I
keep dividing the numbers that I have by
each other and it gets small fast will
be more precise about that in a minute
okay well it's a good exercise in state
machine thinking and practice in program
verification can reformulate the
Euclidean algorithm or formulate
explicitly as a state machine it's very
simple kind of state machine the states
and this Euclidean algorithm state
machine will be pairs if not
so the states are n cross and the
Cartesian product of the non-negative
integers with itself the start state is
going to be the pair a B whose GCD I
want to compute and the transitions are
simply repeatedly applying the remainder
lemma
namely if I have a fell Maine state mix
Y where you think of X's and Y is the
GCD that I'm trying to compute I simply
convert x and y to y and the remainder
of X divided by Y and I keep doing that
as long as Y is not 0 okay very simple
state machine really just one transition
rule well according to the lemma since
I'm replacing the JC thing of x and y by
the GCD of Y and the remainder of X
divided by Y the GCD is actually staying
constant this transition preserves the
GCD that's left in the pair of registers
x and y so what we can say is that since
the GCD of X & Y doesn't change from one
step to another we can say that the GCD
of x and y at any point is equal to its
original value which is the GCD of a and
B so in other words this equation GCD of
X & Y and the current state is equal to
GCD of a and B the GCD of a and B that
we started with is a preserved invariant
of the state so P of a state X Y the
property that gcd of x and y is the
original GCD is a preservative variant
of the state machine
moreover P of star is trivially true
because at the start x and y are a
equals base other so P of X and y is
just saying that you see D of a and B is
equal to GCD of a and B cool so I've
gotten that this property is true at the
start and it's preserved by the
transitions so the invariance principle
tells me that if the program stops I'm
gonna have the gcd of x and y when it
terminates is equal to the actual GCD
that I want and that enables us to prove
partial correctness the claim is that if
this program terminates and we haven't
determined that it does yet but at
termination if
any I claim that the that X is left in
that the GCD of a and B is left in
register X the value of x at the end is
going to be the GCD of a and B well why
is that we'll look at termination what
we know is that Y is 0 that's the only
way that this procedure stops because
otherwise the transition rule is
applicable so that means that when y
equals 0 of termination what we have is
that since Y is 0 GCD of X & Y is equal
to the GCD of X and 0 and that's equal
to x1 assuming again that X is positive
or not 0 so X is the GCD of X or Y and
by the invariant the GCD of x and y is
equal to the GCD of a and B so I've
proved this little fact this procedure
correctly computes the GCD of a and B
leaving the answer in register X if it
terminates well of course it terminates
and it terminates fast so let's see Y
notice is that at each transition we're
going to replace X by Y and Y by the the
remainder of X divided by Y let's just
assume for simplicity that love the
pairings one in X is the bigger one so
there's two cases of Y this these
numbers are getting small fast the first
case is supposed that Y is less than X
over 2 or less than or equal to x over 2
well since at this step you're gonna
replace our X by Y it means that you're
replacing X by something that's less
than 1/2 X so X gets have the dis step
okay what about if Y is big well if Y is
bigger than X over 2 then the remainder
of X divided by Y is simply X minus y
and it's gonna be less than X over 2 but
that's gonna be the value of y after the
next step so y is gonna be 1/2 either at
this step or the next half a step when
it's replaced by the remainder of x and
y and the net result is that y gets cut
in half or even smaller at every other
step
which means that this procedure can't
continue for more than twice the log to
the base 2 of the original value of y
which is be a number of steps because
that's how many halves you can do before
you start getting hitting zero so we've
just shown that this procedure halts in
logarithmic and logarithmic number of
steps which is the same as saying that
it's about the length of B in binary and
even fewer steps than the length of B in
decimal the GCD algorithm is really very
efficient